[Musique]
malgré la variété des produits surgelés
proposés sur le marché français c'est un
des pays qui en consomment le moins
différentes raisons à cela
points de ventes insuffisant
compartiment grand froid longtemps trop
cher et surtout un manque d'information
du consommateur
comment doit-on acheter stocker et
utiliser les produits surgelés et tout
d'abord qu'est ce qu'un produit surgelé
bien un produit surgelé c'est un produit
de premier choix qui a été soumis très
vite après sa pêche ou après sa récolte
à très basse température de telle
manière que le coeur de l'aliment
atteignent rapidement moins 18 degrés
centigrades ainsi on peut avoir des
produits qu'ils conservent très
longtemps s'ils sont conservés
normalement comme ils doivent l'être
leur fraîcheur et leur saveur les gens
ne savent pas exactement ce que sont les
surgelés ni comment ou les utilisent
posément mais j'ai vu que vous nous
expliquiez exactement ce que nous devons
faire lorsqu'on achète un produit
surgelé il ya évidemment un certain
nombre de vérifications à faire jeter un
petit coup d'oeil déjà aux magasins et
aux meubles où on achète pour être
certain que on est dans de bonnes
conditions dans celle de la chaîne du
froid moins 18 degrés et ensuite il y à
un certain nombre de mentions que l'on
doit trouver sur les emballages et la
première c'est la mention surgelés
ensuite les paquets doivent reporter
mention du poids en grammes et de ce
qu'il ya dedans ou de la composition
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un plat plus cuisiner
et il existe également une date qui est
marqué sur le paquet et qui est la date
de surgélation quel est l'intérêt
économique pour une ménagère vers les
intérêts économiques sont divers tout
d'abord en toute saison et en tout lieu
vous pouvez
consommer à peu près n'importe quel
produit ensuite il ya un intérêt qui
touchent directement le portefeuille de
la ménagère c'est que les prix des
produits surgelés ont été stabilisées au
moment du meilleur court et tous ces
produits surgelés ont-ils les mêmes
valeurs nutritives que les produits
frais oui absolument à une précision
pressé la valeur nutritive du produit
frais lorsqu'il est au maximum de sa
valeur nutritive puisqu'on a surgelé le
produit le légume ou le poisson très
rapidement après la récolte donc au
moment où il a sa valeur nutritive
maximale sur le plan des protéines par
exemple là c'est surtout pour le poisson
que cela joue eh bien c'est exactement
la même qualité que pour un poisson
frais et ont fait d'être souvent un
reproche aux poissons surgelés ont dit
il n'a pas de bruit n'a pas d'odeur ce
point semblait c'est un petit peu trouvé
que la mariée est trop belle c'est
justement parce qu'il est très fait
qu'il n'a pas d'odeur
alors une ménagère qui achètent un
produit surgelé que peut-elle en faire
dans l'immédiat tout d'abord et elle
peut bien sûr le consommer le jour même
à midi ou le soir enfin dans le jour où
elle a acheté ça va pas poser de
problème du tout elle peut le consommer
dans les deux ou trois jours pour ça il
faut tout de même qu'elle est un
réfrigérateur avec un freezer allumé le
produit dans son viseur et puis elle le
smm l'adc la vocation du produit surgelé
elle peut le stocker pendant plusieurs
mois
mais là il va y avoir un certain nombre
de conditions la première est d'acheter
un sac isotherme ce n'est pas une grosse
mise de fond ça doit être entre 15 et 20
francs de faire son marché de surgelés
tout à fait en dernier lieu donc pour
qu'il reste le moins longtemps possible
d'en acheter le plus possible à la fois
comme système bien froid dans leur sac
isotherme de rentrer chez soi tout de
suite et de les mettre immédiatement
dans un compartiment de rouvroy vous
décidez de faire un plat surgelé vous le
sortez du compartiment grand froid
comment l'utiliser bien d'abord il ne
faut pas changer d'avis parce que si les
sorties du comportement grand froid
depuis un certain temps et bien
il ne faut pas leur mettre ensuite eh
bien c'est extrêmement simple vous
sortez votre produit de l'emballage et
vous le faites cuire directement au four
dans la poêle dans la casserole au
court-bouillon enfin comme vous avez
choisi de le faire et ça va très vite
c'est très très très facile alors il ya
quelques exceptions les fruits les pâtes
à rouler qu'il faut faire dégeler
hélas il ne faut pas vouloir aller trop
vite c'est à dire vouloir les faire
déjeuner sur un radiateur ou à landrais
du four ou dans l'eau chaude
il faut attendre le temps voulu mais
pour être sûr de ne pas se tromper et
bien c'est très simple il n'ya qu'à lire
ce qui est écrit sur l'emballage ou
toutes ces précisions sont données
[Musique]